[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
amis du samedi
soir bienvenue sur le plateau du grand
blind le jeu qui connaî la
musique h concours hor concours parce
que trop fort mais indispensable parce
que trop drôle voici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la
[Musique]
mieurs c'est la place
de c'est la place merci beaucoup
mercici pour les filles dis que tu étais
trop fort regard je te sile un truc
[Musique]
par
[Rires]
la
reviens ok ok ok ok je vais faire je
vais faire plus simple plus
simple tu ne te réveilles pas
d'accord je l'ai je l'ai c'est quoi
comme d'habitude
bravo alors
Laurent tu dis je dis candidat bien sûr
bel enchaînement kry c'est du pur
Drucker tu es au
top et pour jouer faire la fête avec
nous qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut des
des gens qui acceptent de venir des
filles et c'est pas facile fa les
filles unri veillant Frédéric Benos
maineor elisa Tovati et Julie Zenati
mesames
oh la brochette comment ça
va fin tes phrases c'était comment le le
sketch que vous avez écrit Laurent pour
Jean-Marie Bigard c'était le lâchet de
[__] mais
bon alors qui dit fille dit garçons
voici les
[Applaudissements]
garçonsard
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir les garçons
bonsoir les filles donc vous avez été
choisis pour participer à la première du
Grand blind test et à la dernière
peut-être
attention impossible
impossible attendez vous allez pas
commencer chaque fois qu'il y a un
jingle à dire ce que c'est bon vous
connaissez le principe c'est très simple
hein je vous fais écouter des des
chansons et puis c'est c'est vraiment
pas compliqué enfin c'est quand même
assez compliqué au fa parce que c'est
pas si simple c'est pas compliqué ou
c'est compliqué le principe est simple
mais les chansons qu'on a choisies sont
pas simple je suis un pe embêté ça va
être très dur je crois que vous aurez
besoin les uns et les autres d'une
assistance médicale
end pour vous éponger le
frontess de pas faire bu Laur c'est le
service public et pour ça j'appelle
Barbara
N et le petit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
PhIP
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors pour jouer faut des équipes vous
êtes 12 on a choisi de faire six équipes
de deux voilà quand tu dis on j'ai
jamais été consulté là-dessus non non
heureusement d'ailleurs
alors donc c'est Barbara et Nancy qui
vont s'occuper du tirage pour les
équipes de TR personnellement avec un H
audessus de tout
soupur
[Applaudissements]
PHPP et donc c'est vous les fillesz
composer les équipes vous tirer Barbara
pour les
fillesindoror avec
[Applaudissements]
lavoineire un duo c'est sûr Maine vous
êtes heureuse Maine d'être avec je suis
ravi on va les exploser à mort on
continue Barbara alors Astrid
Veillon avec Gérard d'ond oh non oh
c'est énorme ah c'est énorme ah c'est
énorme
ah on l'aurait fait exprès on aurait pas
fait mieux Astrid ça va ça va je crois
que vous avez beaucoup de chance hein e
parce que je sais que Gérard a une
grande culture musicale donc je pense
que nous allons vous éclater ce soir
voilà ça c'est fait astd etontophile
Barbara alors ah tu disais pas ça quand
j'étais à côté de toi elisa Tovati elisa
Tovati oui avec Florent P
avec c'est
bienisati est très
heureuse c'est
bien on continue alors Frédric B avec
Laur
bravo est-ce qu'on peir de la déception
de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laurannon effectivement on peut pas dire
qu'il l'air très heureux mais non mais
parce qu'elle m'a dit tout à l'heure
qu'elle était pourrie et moi je suis une
gros quiche
aussi continue Barbara al oui avec
Bernard camp beauou voilà ils
sontjà VO tous les couples sont
form per perdant les
los ça va vous êtes globalement
satisfait de V compagnons oui non non
moi je suis arbitre pour prouver que
rien n'est truqué on va lire les deux
derniers papiers quand
même savoir aussi Jul et et voilà et
voilà bien merci pH
pH un homme au dessus tout soupant
mesdames
[Musique]
messieurs
dis est-ce qu'on peut revoir la la
sortie de Barbara là je sais pas
pourquoi
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parfait je crois que ça vait le coup de
revoir cette scène grand moment de
télévision alors est-ce qu'on peut poser
la première questionry qui a envie de
changer
oui plais pour recommencer s'il vous
plaît vous voudriez être avec qui avec
Laurent baffi ah non c'est pas possible
j'ai pas le droit de jouer alors le
premier prix c'est un weekend ensemble
où vous voulez alors on va
changer
donc Gérard Gérard Veillon Marc Lavoine
avec Maurine T avec Elisa vous deux en
weekend tous les deux Julie ça fait
marrer où vous voulez Campan pareil
voilà bien et alors pour les perdants
parce que malheureusement il y aura une
équipe perdante pour les perdants il y a
un truc
assez assez assez Glob quoi
assez c'est un truc
c'est un truc vraiment bizarre
vraiment bien alors j'explique le jeu
soyez très attentif he Gérard un point
déjà C unme m sympathique déjà donc
d'abord on va faire des illiminatoires l
tu sors on va faire
ensuite ensuite les deux équipes
gagnantes s'affronteront dans une finale
ensuite Elisa gagne on l'attrape voilà
et ensuite c'est ce qui était sur mon
deux membres de l'équipe gagnante
s'affronteront pour savoir qui est le
super super champion et alors pour les
battus il y aura ce qu'on appelle la
finale des battus c'est comme au
championnat du monde c'est
pareil exactement bien alors on passe
donc aux éliminatoires
Didier
alors il le sane qu'est-ce qui chante
laal bravo bravo la Bravo
alors on passe au premier blind test qui
un BL une tèse d'échauffementin de de
mise en forme le principe est simple je
vous fais écouter des des reprises de
chansons connu et vous me dites qui
chantait l'original
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Didier
attention
[Musique]
Philippe bravo
effectivement effectivement c'est une
chanson interprété par yri Buenaventura
mais à l'origine c'est une chanson de
Michel fugin qu'on écoute DJ voilà bravo
fa
pourquarmon tu la connais c'est pas vous
avez compris comment ça se passe chez
vous
aussi
on a tout comis très bien on passe à la
deuxème reprise
Philippe Madonna vous AZ dit Madonna m
Madonna
bravo
Madonna le morceau ici est interprété
par les Lords of the new church
l'original c'était Madonna on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'écoute
[Musique]
attention trè reprise êes arrê
chanterentr maintenant parce que c'est
impressionnant elle est tout ch on trou
pas une réponse attention est-ce que
vous êtes prêt pour la 3è reprise
attention
Philippe qui chantait
l'original
[Musique]
Jos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'original qui
l'original
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
bravo attention
l'original qui s
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'original
bra
[Applaudissements]
laise encore un point attention ça se
complique bien
[Musique]
évidment
oh
[Musique]
Dav oh oui qui chantait l'original David
B très bien très bien bravo
bravo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'Origin Didier je voudrais qu'onécoute
un bout de la version française de
Gérard
[Musique]
PAL ous le
ciel
[Musique]
n attention attention
Philippe qui a interprété
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'original
voilà cette version c'est et l'original
c'est on écoute l'original
[Musique]
dure attention
PhIP qui a fait
[Musique]
l'original
gbourg non gansbourg non non qui a fait
l'original attention ah j'avais dit que
ça deviendrait un peu plus un peu plus
compliqué P à la pub café un
[Musique]
peu me du peut pas dire le titre de la
chanson on peut pas dire le titre de la
chanson non je ve le groupe à quoi à
quoi bravo
alors alors alors la VO vous nous avez
dit qui à qui bravo Barbie Girl la
reprise de Axel
BO on écoute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'original
[Musique]
bien alors le rappel des scores à
l'issue de ce premier
blind oui si je peux me permettre moi
j'ai pas du tout aimé le doigt d'honneur
que nous a fait Mar quand il a trouvé la
réponse
[Musique]
repay
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le de la compé le Rapp des Scor donc
c'est vous Mar Lavoine avecindor qui gag
3 points il vont partir weekend
em on passe maintenant au
deèiminatoir le principe est simple je
vous fais écouter des chanteurs dont ce
n'est pas le métier et vous devez me
dire qui c'est voilà elisa Tovati ce
blind test pourrait vous être dédié
parce que vous ce n'est pas au départ
votre métier de de chanter au départ
vous êtes comédienne et donc vous avez
sorti un album qui s'appelle ange
étrange et le single le deuxème single
s'appelle
j'avance
j'aV
et
j'avance voilà alors c'est album qui a
été écrit parckon les frères AX Renoir
Patrick
bu
sur
bien quis que votre promo est [__]
complètement
là tout vas-y
vas-yance je crois c'est ce qu'on
appelle sa promo non mais il a une promo
tout à l'heure aussi vous croyez je peux
faire la même
chose une très bonne promo
ça parler de votre disque enfin mon
petit je c'est donc c'est c'est mon
c'est donc mon premier album mais ce que
j'ai envie de dire parce que Marc
Lavoine est à côté de moi donc j'en
profite pour le remercier publiquement
c'est grâce à Marc à l'Olympia au
Théâtre de la Porte Saint-Martin j'ai
fait mes premiers pas sur scène et
j'étais en première partie de ces
concerts et je voulais le remercier
parce que c'est rare de donner la chance
comme ça oh que c'est
beaualit au-delà de l'album et cetera
bien alors on passe maintenant au
blindest les
chanteurs pas être content il faut
mettre une couche il est bien son album
mais j'ai pas d'attaché de presse vous
pouvez y aller non il faut redire un
compliment termine sur un petit
compliment sur l'album qui moi je trouve
ça vachement bien je l'écoute chez
moi tu crois que la
proop dit que c'est trop bien c'est pas
grave alors on passe au blind test des
chanteurs dont ce n'est pas mé le
[Musique]
métier bien est-ce que vous êtes prêt
larmand moi je suis prêt bien alors on
va vous faire écouter ch vous allez nous
dire vous allez nous dire qui chante
attention c'est pas leur métier
attention
Philipp oh là là
[Musique]
lesu vous m'avez dit m'z m' dit répte je
répéter ou Lionel Jos bravo Lionel
d'ailleurs on regarde effectivement la
révélation
qui nous
ressemble moi qui
[Musique]
m'aim rappelons simplement pour mémoire
que lonnais a les couilles de mettre un
terme à sa
carrière sal
il chanteur pas du tout le métier
Philippe
oui faisons
l'amour
avant vous m'avez dit le
bravo mais comment vous savez ça vous
j'en ai entendu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parler
c'est
[Musique]
accé voil cétait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Jez point on continue les chanteurs non
ce n'est pas le métier
[Musique]
Philippe
pas rejoue
attention jouer chez vous
attention oui bravo vous avez JAC
bravo Jack Long absolument Jack Long
avec Linda Hardy bravo Jack
[Musique]
Long
regarde-mo
moi
très bien on passe maintenant au 4e
chanteur dont ce n'est pas le métier
incroable incroyable attention Philippe
un indice chez
vous qu'est-ce
[Musique]
chante c'est
[Applaudissements]
bra
[Musique]
on continue on continue
Philippe de ouais ça Karen mlder
[Musique]
non c'est pas Karen mer est venu là
attention ne de Neu non de Neu non c'est
pas loin VI c'est pas loin non
non
non c'est très
[Applaudissements]
difficile
française faut pas être voyant sans
déconner alors un indice un indice
Laurent c'est Élisabeth pessier mais non
un indice oh merde je m'y ferai
jamais bon personne marque
évidemment oui tu as raison un indice je
dois pas dire le nom c'est toi qui a
raison [__] y arri thier on va faire
une super émission allez on
[Musique]
continue ah non non
[Applaudissements]
ch laiss ça
rien son les cons
voilà c'était donc effectivement
ellisabeth Tessier bravo je l'avais dit
bravo Elisabeth Timy Mames
messieurs
attention
introuvable
pas
[Musique]
inouvable Clinton non Clint pas lo pas
loouv av connu la
sant indice pour vous ah si vous aviez
connu la Sophie d'avant oui
[Musique]
effectivement
bra
[Musique]
voilà
c'éta attention continue encore plus
difficile ce n'est pas son métier non
plus
[Musique]
PhIP
attention isisa non non cétait
nerveux on ira tous au
[Musique]
paradis
les
tous
[Musique]
on
la il il ence Monseigneur
[Musique]
attention
vousz Monseigneur ga bravo
effectivement a tous au
Paradisi qu'on soit béni pour
soi et bon seur tous les voleurs j'ai
teis tous les btils on ira
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
surtout moi Monseigneur g absolument
Bravo
bravoer est alors 6 pour Marc Lavoine
pour Mar Lavoine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bra et 27 pour
Gérard D un point ouais
bravo Hollande 1 pointoui quand je dis
je parle du couple je parle de Monsieur
et Madame DVE donc ça fait un point camp
0 point dis la fin de la
blague Laurent de chez Frédéric Bedos
oui je crois Laurent de chez Frédéric
Bedos un point Gand Veillon 3
points et flent
voil donc les perdants sont pour le
moment
Bernard
tréie et oui c'est une tragédie c'est
une tragédie pour N et Bernard Campan
qui ont bien besoin du soin de nos
infirmers perdre pour se faire masser ah
d'accord un moment dans la vie il faut
choisir et Florent P vient de
reconnaître les bgies bravoou bravo
Florent P alors que les B ne l'ont pas
reconnu les B ne l'ont pas reconnu mais
lui a reconnu les B manque de posuse ça
ne joue pas et voilà tant pis c'est un
peu j'aura gagné alors maintenant donc
on va passer au 3è blindest oui la pub
non il y a pas de pub il y a pas de pub
c'est le service musi autant pour moi
donc je vais vous faire entendre des
répliques de film et vous donnerez le
titre du film si vous le voulez ch mais
avant tant qu'on est dans le tant qu'on
est dans le cinéma je voulais parler du
film dont vous êtes l'un des acteurs
avec Marc Labine merci Laurent et
Bernard Campan et Jean-Pierre darous la
promo attention vous êtes tous les trois
à la fiche d'un film aux excellentes
répliquesa tu es prête un film aux
excellentes répliques qui s'appelle le
cœur des hommes de marque Esposito non
non je l'aime trop ce film je vais faire
le pit che quatre potes qui se
connaissent depuis 25 ans il y a Darmon
qui est un patron de presse blasé qui
refait sa vie avec une jeunesse qui est
zoé Félix il y a la voix vous êtes
l'associé de de darand B fou fou
fou fou camp prof de gym détruit car
votre épouse vous trompe comme ce soir
absolument détr effectivement
etc
célibataire alors donc ça s'appelle le
cœur des hommes c'est sorti depuis
mercredi c'est un film un petit peu dans
l'esprit de Vincent François Paul et les
autres où les films vivent Robert comme
un éléphant ça trompe énormément nous
irons tous au paradis sauf que ça se
passe en en 2003 et que bah les femmes
ont changé de depuis l'époque des films
don dont je parlais qui veut prendre la
parole en premier bah je pense que c'est
Campan parce que dans le film il est
assez malheureux donc les femmes ont
changé nous sommes en 2003 et les hommes
ont le cœur un petit peu
déstabilisé les eff beaucoup changé est
2003 coucou on est en
2003 les
femmescoupém ce il est super en forme je
pense que c'est lui faut que tu poses
des questions les femmes ont changé
énormé je te
J je t' jamais trpé rardc c'est toute
seu pourquoi tu crois que je suis en
retard il y a les hommes libres il y a
les autres il hommes heureux et j'aime
pas quand je rentre chez moi qu' a
personne mais p-toi un chat je préférera
une
[Musique]
chatte j'aimerais dormir avec vous mais
je vais pas être capable de faire
l'amour avec vous si moi je peux
m'endormir à côté de vous sans vous
toucher est-ce que c'est pas un peu
vexant je rêve de ce qu'on peut avoir
qu'une
fois un Amour pour toujours ou là garçon
la
déciou
c'est ce qu'on appelle une épreuve tu
dois l'accepter est bhiste charuti ça va
pas ou quoi ça va pas du
tout pas poser la morete
question temp Mar du
fille bien
jeunette'estce que jeisé
Mo je neuf faut voir comment ça tourne
tu PES pas du
[Musique]
tout menteur et toi toujours frétillant
ah non je me calme trop de boulot ils
ont encore grossi c'est magnifique c'est
beau la MO ça fou les
jetons oh elles ont morfé les SP g
[Musique]
les voilà ouais le cœur des hommes de
marque exposit mesames messieurs c'est
en salle depuis
mercredii en ce moment c'est top à vous
là ça va
ou mon métier
ou le film doit marcher parce qu'ils ont
pas envie de faire la promo on a vach
envie tu rigoles non non mais bien sûr
maison une question et je n'ai pas la
réponse
je le tout c'est que vous ayez les
réponses du blind test merci très bien
OK
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon attention on repart sur les choses
sérieuses on reste dans le cinéma donc
avec ce fameux blind qui s'appelle dans
quel film entend-on ses répliques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Didier j'exlique la règle du je entendre
effectivement les fameuses répliques de
de cinéma vous avez pas le droit de
buzzer jusqu'à la fin de la première
réplique on est bien d'accord ok c'est
vu attention Philippe alors vraiment
écoutezillère c'est
formidable get attention
fac
bravo le Père Noël est une ordure Anemon
et thmite
ouais
alors vraiment écoutez alors thére une
serpillère c'est formidable c'est
amusant c'est formidable c'est un
gilet bien sûr c'est un gilet il y a des
trous plus grands pour les bras bien
sûr je suis ravi Thérèse je me disais
toujours qu'il manquait quelque chose
pour descendre les poubelles je suis
ravition
elle est
pas DIUE de
mich
jeverention rép pheve il est riche riche
comme moi et catholique comme tout le
monde comme tout le monde monsieur c'est
bon
unest un petit g je vous en
suppli attention elisaati Raby Jacob
Raby Jacob effectivement lou de fun h
les aventures de r
jacard avec gardand effectivement c'est
bon j'ariez pu le trouver ça quand même
mais par descens par des bien magto ser
il a un cheveux m est riche riche comme
moi et catholique comme tout le monde
pas comme tout le monde monsieur parce
que moi par exemple je suis
juif vous êtes juif comment Salomon vous
êtes
juif Solomon et juif oh voilà les
inventurs de Ramy
Jacob
c'est clair non non non moi je tiens à
dire pour ceux qui nous rejoignent en
cours d'émission qu'on vient de nous
spoer TR
pointsou
pas c'est bon écrivez-nous pour les
réclamations absolument la chev
on
si à la
fraîche décontracté du
gland et on bandera quand on aura envie
de bander on est là on est dessus
normalement c'est nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien ch de ton
danstion pas bien si
paisible à la
fraîche décontractter du Gl
et on bandera quand on aura envie de
bander voilà les valceuses bravo ça fait
un point pour l'équipe de Frédéric bel
et la Bravo suis arriv quand vous vous
donnez un peu de mal il faut envoyer des
sacrés patates la Patat dans le buzzer
tu as raison
attentionz
pas je suis un
homme personne n'est
parfait c'est un très viux film alors je
j'essaye he la cage au fol
non c'est bien la peine d'abîmer le
buzzer je caresse comment comment il
fait comment il fait a et oui on tap fa
a c'est normal qui connait la réponse
l'assassin 21 qui les hommes préfèrent
les blondes entendu moi pas lo chaud
chaud ou
bravo
certain
cétaiton effectivement
comprz pas
ce je suis un
homme personne n'est
parfait voilà pour ceux qui souvenent
pas du film voilà certain même ch de
Billy Wilder voilà est Mor l'année
dernière bien bien on va voir les scores
à l'issue de cette épreuve mal baisse
baisse Lavoine et morindor 6
points
points deut 3 points aussi c'est pas
Malis toujours Z0 point làdessus je
crois vous êtes
brillant et julieenti un point et darand
d'Armand veillant 5 points donc pour le
moment c'est entre vous deux 6 pour vous
C pour eux attention on passe au blind
test numéro 4 le principe alors c'est
très simple je vais vous donner des des
paroles de chanson aux garçons et vous
allez les lire à votre hongrois ça c'est
pour toi a gagné vous allez lire à votre
coéquipière qui doit trouver de quelle
chanson il s'agit ça s'appelle qui a
chanté sesanneries voilà n vous qui
présentez le Top 50 sur sur MCM vous
devez en entendre des anneries non pas
mal ou pas mal d'anneries je vous
rappelle que NES présente le Top 50 sur
MCM du lundi au samedi donc à 19h et
vous présentez top of the Pops le
mercredi à 17h55 sur France 2 rediffuser
le samedi à 18h on devait demander
quelle est la plus belle merde du moment
ce serait quoi on a vachement de chance
parce qu'il y a jamais eu autant de
bonnes choses dans le classement du top
album
franchement et non non et je non je
pense je pense com du
bois à M 3D je pense à s Severino je
pense à des gens comme ça bah s'il y
avait pas des émissions top of the Pops
on les verrait pas tout à fait vive comm
c'est du bois
[Applaudissements]
ouais
Frédéric Bedos est-ce que vous entendez
beaucoup d'annerie vous dans votre
émission sur MCM aussi qui s'appelle One
to One une fois par mois ah non ah bah
non moi c'est fixé sur que le Must ouais
bah ouais on passe au blind qui a chanté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses Gérard arm àon vous prenez vos MICR
vous prenez voilà très bien vous aussi
voilà
vous venez au centre voilà Gérard je
vous donne ses paroles vous allez les
lire et ASR doit trouver de quel
interprète il s'agit attention bien sûr
tais-toi donc écoute-moi attention parf
chopz choper choper le kumkoum avant que
ce soit le kumkoum qui vous chope choper
choper choper le kumkoum c'est pas le
mec de m6ére pas ce que je
disc c'est meal alors que le kumkoum
vous
échappez Félix Gray non non non voilà
donc vous avez perdu merci bah oui oui
ou c'est Félicien c'est pas vous qui
l'avez trouvé on a été ridicule merci
beou non pas ridicule perdant gresque
non pas grotese perdant Magneto
[Musique]
Serge ch ch ch ch le cou
couou
chauff ch Chau
chauff av trouvé connaissiez pas
connaisse pas je suis contente de pas
avoir trouvé moi en
faitant c'est tour de Marc Lavoine
donc vas-y tu peux continuer ça
t'intéresse pas du tout ce que Mar
lavoineindor donc Marc vous liseer ses
paroles à morindor tu vas te marer
c'estach
exactement tu
qu' bonour est-ce que tu viens pour les
vacances je peux dire tout de suite on
va c'est David et Jonathan bravo vous
marqu
un
les moi je n'ai pas
changéadress je ser je pense un peu en
avance au
rendezvous sur vous attention attention
donnez-moi la fiche attention dans le T
que vous
voulez allez viens boire un petit coup à
la maison allez viens il y a du blanc du
rouge du saucisson et Gilou avec son
petit accordéon allez vivre les
bouteilles et les copains et les
chansons
alorsisa c'était c'était pas force
4 alors je peux l'aider oui oui ah bon
cétait les licen
ou bravo vous marquez un point
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maisou y a Damon qui a une ou moi je
conteste je vous demandeavoir une autre
question parce que c'est pas une
question virtuelle que j'ai eu personne
ne connait chop mais si tout le monde
connaît
merci les jeunes connaissent Dave c'est
à vous maintenant Dave et Julie
Zenati tiens mon petit tiens voilà dev
allez-y et tu chantes chantes chantes ce
refrain qui te plaît et tu tapes tapes
tapes c'est ta façon d'aimer ce rythme
qui t'entraîne jusqu'au bout de la nuit
réveille entoi le tbillon de vant de
folie
de soirée c'est début de
soirée bon allez on vous donne le point
parce que vous êtes trop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
joli début de soirée oui début de soir
abumentbut je tiens juste à dire que je
n'étais pas né oui voilà c'est tout
Bernard niss au boulot allez-y mes
enfants depuis le début on trouve tout
là ouis là je do dire c'est une son
c'est une occasion pour vous c'est une
occasion pour vous de marquer un
point attention Bernard chante ouais
chante danse B a tes baskets c'est les
for B les for
bravo ça y est ils ont trouvé un truc
ils ont marqué un point ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
deou
personne fort bon bravo bravo voyez que
j''y arrivé quand même non mais ça c'est
fast ah bah fast pas
tellement Laurent deut che Frédéric B
s'il vous plaît prenez vos
MICR alors on y va vous faites un beau
couple le weekend va être réussi ah mais
je suis ravi papa papa tuas pas encore
zappé regarde un peu regarde la brun que
je teamène à la
maison tu
connaisjà dans une car vous irez où en
weekend si vous gagnez àreux ah oui à
proposé un petit
routier sur la bosse attention attention
allez-y je te survivrai d'un amour
vivant je te survivrai dans des jeux
d'enfant je te survivrai un ancien JRE
de foot qui jou à Saint-Étienne je te
survivrai avec une nucllon un peu à la
comme un je t'assure je peux la chanter
si tu veux mais à part Laurent dites-le
si vous le savez mais c'est Jean-Pierre
François bravo
bravo vous marquez un point incroyable
on est ravi un rebondissement
incroyable c'est un peu comme l'école
des fans
non Serge
amour vivant je te survivrai dans des
yeux d'enfant je te survivrai comme un
revenant je te
survivrai
je te
survivrai tu
m'entends je te
surviv quel toi je te
surivd de moi je
te Jean-Pierre François je te
survivrai
précis j'aimerais juste dire que j'ai
gagné ce pointl grâce à Bernard Campan
pour ceux qui se souviennent il avait
fait une parodie de Jean-Pierre François
dans les inconnus et moi je me rappelis
que de la parodie en fait
mercici comme quoi ça sert d'être
comique qu'est-ce qui se passe version
orig c'est will
survive non mais e et si on mettait un
point d'Armon ou
bravoo il en a déjà beaucoup quand
même bien alors les scores maintenant
les scores alors euh des
2 oh là là
avec Jul arriv à de pour ceux qui en
douterai
encore Bernard
camp laurch et frédri ça va beaucoup
mieux vous êtes à
4on vous êtes 2è avec 6
points alors évidemment
lavoindor
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bra et P pas
Malti 4
points et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
bien
alors je sais sauf que ça joue pas voyez
dès que ça joue pas tout le monde trouve
et quand ça joue personne trouve alors
maintenant on va
écouter
dans qu
grandmère c'est une ta
grandmère ta
grand-mère c'est une brun grand mer qui
chantait l'original chat dans le
miroir j'ai vu ta chatte dans le
miroir chatte dans le
miroir j'ai vu ta chat dans le
miroir dans le
rtro qui vous êtes
sur vous êtes sur le service public qui
chantter l'original Mor bravo je BZ
ouais alors on va écouter des rires
maintenant alors donc vous allez me dire
à qui appartienne une C rire l ce blind
test pourrait vous être dédié parce que
vous avez vraiment une patate d'enfer
vous êtes souvent touchant mais toujours
drôle et après le ciel je fais ta promo
décne après le ciel les oiseaux et ta
mère non mais après chat dans le rétro
bit dans le tiroir et tout ça va être
chaud de faire ma promo ti on va parler
de Dutch maintenant parlant de B ma
place mon garçon donc après le ciel les
oiseaux et ta mère après Jet 7 et 3-0
avant les ripou 3 super ripou avec noir
et l'ermite vous êtes actuellement à
laaffiche Laurand DCH souvenez-vous d'un
film qui s'appelle bienvenue chez les
roses tout à fait al c'est une comédie
cruelle décalé de Francis paluo avec
vous avec Francis non pas Francis avec
Jean du jardin mais c'est assez simple à
se retenir des noms c'est que des noms
qui ont un rapport avec le terroir il y
a Jean du jardin il y a Carole Bouquet
Clémence poésie puis Laur mais bon c'est
le Touch quoi une plante qui pousse
[Applaudissements]
qu'appartement ce soir c'est niage de
promo ce soir c'est clair c'est niage de
promo voilà je pense que les attaché de
presse Laurent vous aviez raison les
attachés de press vont pas être très
content mais vous faites bien de me vous
voyz mais je pense la que c'est normal
très bonne chose mais c'est normal il a
joué à bzier en 92 Laurent voilà
excusez-moi de vous le dire alors le
pitch vous voulez quand même que jeasse
le pit ou alors c'est de toard évadés
qui débarquent dans une famille
charmante qui habite dans une maison
charmante enelière en meelière voilàir
un email pour dire enfin une émission en
direct bravo ou
je il était temps que je me mette en
direct je crois que là l'instant c'est
marrant ces emails sont con les
gens donne
du mais alors les gangsters s'avèent
beaucoup moins dangereux que la famille
chez qui il débarque c'est pe dire c'est
vraiment un film sur les apparences où
on va se rendre compte assez tôt que les
choses ne sont pas ce ce qu'on croit
qu'elles sont voilà et et nous qui
sommes au départ supposé être des Truant
évader de prison évadé de fourgon de
transfert de prisonniers on va pas être
si auu que ça de toute façon quand on
voit mon physique de chevrefeuille on se
doute que il y a une couille dans le
potage pour reprendre la chanson de
Gérard Armand très très bien et c'est
donc peu à peu les gangsters qui ont
peur de la famille voilà qui va se
révéler odieuse voilà et votre
personnage alors c'est un type terrible
s toujours fait complètement manipulé
très passif et qui
réfugie dans la nature car il a compris
que toute chose doué de de raison se
retournerait contre lui en permanence il
a aucune volonté il a aucun pouvoir de
décision c'est un pauvre mec ouais alors
il y a une vraie alchimie une vraie
osmose avec Jean du jardin qui est sur
cette chaîne d'ailleurs tous les soirs
un gars une fille vous êtes bien entendu
ouais mortel c'est un bon assut à moi
maintenant un bon copain en plus il est
assez beau donc voilà si vous voulez
rencontrer gens du jardin vous pouvez
passer par moi voilà ça vous coûtera que
quelques petites palpations Magneto
Serge Danel chéri le prend pas mal je
suis un peu débordé on a un légère
imprévu
oh non pas le jour de Mos de porcelain
deux allumés complets ils ont tuer deux
collègues avec leurs propres armes vous
allez nous violer et nous tuer vous
voulez boire quelque chose j'avais prévu
du champagne mais vu la situation
préférez peut-être sortez de chez moi ta
gueuleéchir je comprends que tu m'en ve
mais j'étais pas du tout fait pour être
MRE si c'était àire j'avortera vous avez
dû tué pas mal de gens dans votre
activité vous pouvez bienosser un mort
de plus bien ça oh le con le con le con
non honnêtement je pouvais pas
m'attendre à ça de la part de Monsieur
rose vous aimez les dessins
animés jusqu'à ce soir j'ai jamais osé
me laisser aller alors que c'est si bon
d'être une belle [__] r me laiss faire
c'est pas moi
tu peux gueer t que tu veux je me casse
cette bar de T qu'est-ce que vous avez
tous dans cette famille normal tout ce
qu' a plus normal voilà bienvenue chez
les roses de Francis T avec B je jordin
et Laur Dutch qui est notre invité ce
soir mesdames messieurs voilà alors
comment ça se passe super ripou avec
Noiré l'ermite ça se passe très très
bien ouais ouais c'est des fois je crois
que Philippe Noiré comprend pas tout ce
que je dis ouais mais il est très gentil
et c'est non c'est vraiment très
savoureux très confortable comme
tournage claud Zili c'est vraiment
impressionnant de travailler avec lui et
alors à partir du 22 avril vous êtes au
théâtre de l'Ouest parisien à boulon
Bill encour sur scène pour la reine de
beauté de
tout à fait de Martine mdonal adaptation
et mise en scène de gildaz BOURD ouais
ça claque aussi là ça claque aussi ouais
c'estatration un CV c'est assez brillant
ça do c'est formidable ce qui vous
arrive là non bah ouais je bientôt me
réveiller avant il chouina aujourd'hui
on peut le dire il attrape ah il attrape
vous attrapz un peu là non ça commence
ouis ouais je crois que y a des filles
qui commencent à poser leur regard sur
moi elles ont appris à faire un
mouvement du coup comme ça regarder vers
le bas et voir ici là le petit aussi je
veux taper va y avoir du sport mais
moi va y avoir du SP
mais moi je
rest attention on reste dans le rire
donc avec le blind test flent
panier à qui est ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rire attention attention à qui est ce
rire
Philippe h Salvador
oi
ou il a pas de
c'est soués une émission de télé avec
lui il y a 3 ans je l'ai côtoyé pendant
une semaine et je vais te dire le
premier son on sa déjà que c'est lui il
a le rire le plus reconnaissable de
France
[Applaudissements]
désoléage alors bravo pour le deuxème je
peux donner un indice donne un indice
alors pour Bernard qui qui a un point
avec sa copine ouais écoute Bernard
alors s'il vous crache à la gueule c'est
normal
magnet Serge laain on va
dire comm rapidité là ou bien il faut il
a un peu aidé BFF non bien mais céit
[Applaudissements]
pVu on continue
Philippe
a ça c'est Laurent r Laurent r l'
reconnu c'est
normal vous êtes à bonne école tous les
jours école vous pensez quoi du rire de
Laurent rupier ah il est quand même
assez énorme parce qu'il est à la fois
sorti et à la fois rentré il en a un peu
honte et en même temps il le sort donc
c'est on est
d'accord ça VI résumer sa vie c'est vrai
qu' rentre un
[Applaudissements]
peu tu es assez rentré là bien attention
c'est très très très compliqué ou non
pas d'indice pas d'indice pas pas
d'indice
non prén non non Laurent non écoute il
faut qu'il y ait un jeu quand même
attention
Philippe pour ville non qui sait qui
sait franchement vous êtes tous des
ringardsin il a donné un indice
oui êesous
tous
[Applaudissements]
jeierre bravo bravo
ouais
ou donc je le rappelle les scores en
vitesse oui 2 pour Dave et Julie
Zenati
bra 1 pour Bernard Campon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et plus alors ça remonte pour vous vous
êtes à 5 c'est pas mal ça remonte bon
c'est bon c'est pas à l'abri de
l'embarqueur weekend la petite he
e c'est surtout pour pour Darmont 7 et
pour maindor et Marc Lavoine bravo
ouais ce sont les grands gagnants pour
le moment et Florent P elisaati 5 bravo
c'est bien aussi c'est
bien bien on est quand même venu on est
là attention on passe au blind test
numéro 6 qui chantait l'original
massacré par Cadé Olivier attention je
vous rappelle les la règle non attendez
je rappelle la règle du jeu donc euh le
buzzer est bloqué jusqu'à la fin du
Magnetto de l'extr ça nous empê pas de
la booné voilà attention dit qui
chantait les originaux massacré par
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Olivier il v
[Musique]
JeanMichel
c'est Bernard Bernard oui l non c'est
c'est alors qui chantait l'original
massacré par CanéO B oui je
sais quoi quoi de quoi allez
vas-yzvous parrez-vous qu'est-ce que
vous croyez on en a 15 on passe un coup
de P on en a 15 comme vous mais
barrez-vous monsieur Labine
monsieur
moi on nous
déjà tu vas
pasem tu plus à ce stade de ta
carrière mais non mais ne traite pas
comme ça la
j'uris son des invités la non ils ont
perdu ils sont
pas c'est tout alors maintenant faut
trouver le nom voilà
Johnny oua
ou très très bien effectivement c'était
johnnyid me donne envie
absolument il açu un don de la nature à
sa naissance sur la comp des chanteurs
inconnu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeanmich californ Absolum absolument
mais
c'est bande de
naz pas bien les paroles de son
[Musique]
préférémichel mais une partie du
mal pas juste il déj la vie est
injuste la réponse c'est quoi Daniel BAV
[Applaudissements]
dan vousz un point très
bien on continue donc
[Musique]
attentionich
je
CZ in incapable de
jouer pyam
question son empli c'est Jean-Michel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
satur
2 1
attention c'est comme ça alors c'est qui
Stev Wonder
[Applaudissements]
ouais j'ai ce jeu mais c'est
bonry juste je rappelle c'est injuste
non attendez vous tapez pendant
l'extrait on tape après
tout le monde tape on tape tous
pendant il y en a un qui tape au moment
voilà trope et bien je ne suis pas
d'accord si vous aussi chez vous vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ces règles
lamentables envoyez des sms 2,40 € la
minute 10 c'est scandaleux dites-le
révoltez-vous les gosses et donnez du
pognon bien
alors les SCOR
les SCOR de points pour je comprends
qu'ilasse le M 3
campêes à
on est bien on est
bien
aussiom pr pour
[Musique]
vousou tour un petit peu vers vous c'est
normal comme par hasard ça tombe dessus
après le succès de série télé où vous
êtes devenu une star comme Extrême
Limite jamais 203 cré numéro 1 numéro 1
numéro
1é Fabio Montal vous débarquer sur les
planches à Strid et on est très étonné
parce que d'un seul coup on découvre
quelqu'un qui sait écrire qui qui en
tout cas a essayé d'écrire et qui a qui
a réussi à écrire une pièce de théâre
voilà ça s'appelle la salle de bain céit
écrit par vous joué par vous avec Pascal
Roberts Florent gentil Mathilde Pénin
Hélène souberan alors le pit est très
simple le soir de ces 30 ans alors que
la fête basson plein loulou c'est vous
s'enferme dans la salle de bain et
discute avec ses copines il y a une
espèce de va et vient dans la salle de
bain et il se passe une soirée à côté et
voil voilà va et vient oui suff fait de
peu de chos pour s'exer tout le monde
quand même en même temps les buzzers
aussi magnet Serge je te rappelle que
que ce sont tes 30 ans ce soir et que
tes amis sont venus pour s'amuser pour
rigoler tu l'as vu hier sur chez Castel
il était avec qui il était seul ou
accomagn il rest tard ça t'intéresse
mais pas du tout c'est quoi Pénélope
pourquoi tu me parles de cette espèce de
Marité prtenuse de cette erreur de la
nature alors comment ça va ça va plutôt
mal je me sens seule névrosé déprimé je
le sais je le sens et tout le monde s'en
fou et toi je connais que des hommes
mariés qui trompent leurs femmes j'ai de
quoi je parle vu que je tombe que sur
des hommes mariés les hommes sont tous
dordus dur stupide prétentieux entre les
é talons les guments et les culottes de
cheval c'est plus un salon c'est les
bonomes d'
taille salle de bain la Stre Veillon
c'est à la Comédie de Paris mise en
scène de Jean-Luc Morau voilà
alors stred vous êtes ici vous êtes ici
en tant que spécialiste des relations
hommefemme spécialiste en tout cas je
donne un regard différ sur les relation
après j'ai le duo des gens qui couch ou
qui couch pas k on y va d'accord et ben
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parti qui couche ou qui couche donc vous
devz d'abord me donner le nom du duo et
ensuite me dire sil couch ensemble ou s
couch pas ensemble attention
Philippe couche ensemble chez la Ringo
les la Venise che Ringo à l'époque il
couch ensemble bra vous marquez un point
il était pding attention
[Musique]
philippeite bien ça s allumé as ve
al le duo il cou
ensemble sa
pas
pH
il ne couche pas
bravo bravo quo
que êtes sû de
ça s à l'épo ave
[Musique]
attention il couche pas
ensembleisa il couche pas ensemble et
c'est jodassin non non
non il nont pas cché ensemble donc
Dalida Alain Delon effectivement bravo
il ne couch pas ensemble bravo attention
[Musique]
Didier
j
[Applaudissements]
bra est-ce qu'il couchem est- qu'il
onouch
regarde pas ça ne nous regarde pas
d'accord
mais non mais attention
[Musique]
Philippe mais c'est ici que ça s
allécoutez-moi il en premier oua et Bard
pour ce qui n'ent pas encore bien
compris les
Aigles donc il s'agit bien sa et Bardo
et ils ont crouché ah bravo bravo ils
ont crouché absolument ils ont crouché
ensemble tout à fait absolument et
depuis c'est le mépris he et depuis
c'est le mépris attention les
scores 23 pour d REM 11 points pour vous
11 points pour vous 11 points pour vous
9 points pour eux voilà ils ont marqué
une fois il passe de 7 à 11 je suis
désolé oui ils ont 11 moi j'ai 11
là-dessus là j'ai 11 et nous et toi tu
as neu quoi c'est pas mal ne énorme
c'est mieux que c'est mieux que qu' TR
c'est muxang à 3 je l'ai aussi la FOL ne
j'ai tous les points on était à 7 on éit
à moi j'ai C REPL alors maintenant nous
passons à un blind test intitulé quel
pays représentait cette chanson à
l'Eurovision et je me tourne vers r
parce que vous ne présenterez plus
jamais
l'Eurovision faut jamais dire jamais oui
pourquoi pourquoi mais parce qu'on a dit
trop de conneries peut-être un peu décon
qu'est vous avez fait mais on a dit ce
qu'on pensait mais ça n'a jamais été
aussi génial que mais oui c'està dire
que ça a plu à certaines générations
mais pas à toutes les génération mais
moi j'ai jamais autant regardé que parce
que ça prouve qu'était jeune ça c'est
passé qu'une fois vrai qu' y des choses
qu'est-ce que vous avez dit comme
connerie soire je sais pas en
désannonçant la chanteuse qui
représentai Israël j'ai dit qu' fait
viif ah c'est vra ce moment faire att
donc c'est eu des problèmes avec par
antisémitisme ce qui est quand même
ridicule parce que c'est normal que les
chanteus qui représent serait fait juif
alors Dave peu importe vous publiez un
livre aux éditions Le Pré au clair qui
s'appelle Dave soit dit en passant alors
c'est un livre o vous raconterz vos
années de de gloire et de de galère
d'abord le succès avec trop beau et
comment vous exbitnique vous vous
retrouvez finalement un peu chanteur à
minette quoi d'une certaine façon un peu
star de la variété non ouais
oui oui oui vous voulez pas faire la
promo non
plus moi ça dérange pas il voulait que
ce soit moi qui la fe oui alors alors
dev euh il y a combien de pages dans V
dans votre bouquin dev écrit par moi oui
oh une trentaine j'ai envie de dire je
sais pas hein je l'ai parcouru j'ai
envie de dire qu'il y a plus de
consonnes que de voyelle est-ce que ça a
été pensé à la base c'est on va le faire
avec Thierry peut-être c'est le fruit du
hasard c'est pas bien non plus non c'est
pas ça non
mais moi je l'ai lu son bouquin il a
bien alors donc vous devenez une
chanteuse
[Applaudissements]
à ça c'est un lapsus non ça c'est un
lapsus c'est vraiment c'est le lapsus de
merde c'est le lapsus qui tue voilà ça
venu tellement naturellis et voilà c'est
les qu'est-ce que ça cache vous devenez
un chanteur à minette façon c'est Jérôme
ou Frédéric François ce qui est un
malentendu parce que vous à l'époque
vous aimiez d'autres types de musique
que ça oui enfin disons que moi je
chantais plus les chansons anglo-saxones
voilà bah oui c'est ce que je voulais
dire oui alors après vous êtes pris dans
le tourbillon incontrôlable de la
droguez non vousz un peu arrogant à un
moment quand même non ah oui en 73
comment tu je pense que je suis né
arrogant oui vous devenez arrogant un
petit peu quand même est-ce que c'est
pas ce qu'on appelle en anglais le too
much too soon c'estàd non le trop le
trop le trop trop vite oh too soon à 30
ans ça va quand même pas trop s quand
même alors vous racontez donc ces années
pa 69 non ce qu'il raconte c'est génial
c'est les c'est les les magouilles du
chemise parce que DVE comme il était
avec Patrick l'oiseau effectivement il
pouvait pas dire qu'il était avec
Patrick l'oiseau parce qu'à l'époque ça
se faisait pas évidemment si ça se
faisait mais elle en a parl ça se
faisait par pas oui ça se fait depuis
longtemps vous avez raison donc là vous
vous racontez un petit peu comment tout
ça les reportages bidonnés c'està-dire
qu'on vous fait faire des photos avec
des filles que vous connaissez à peine a
commencé par la directrice de la
promotion non c'est une erreur c'est une
erreur erreur on peut pas donner son nom
là non parce que c'était finalement son
assistante et c'est donc elle elle m'a
appelé à juste ce titre oui je je dirai
pas son nom donc voilà donc a fait une
photo je c la a fait une photo avec la
directrice de la promotion de CBS non
non
non je ce la mais bon pas
questionit pas question de parler
deatiseau alors vous racontez aussi dans
ce Bouin votre votre la jalousie qui a
entre Gérard Lenormand et vous vous
racontez la grossièrté de claud François
a des anecdotes mais il y en a même que
j'ai enlevé parce anecdote avec raconte
avec Florent et finalement je l'ai en je
l'ai enlevé parce que en fait c'est
c'était pas gentil non pas contre toi
mais c'est une anecdote où à un moment
j'étais on était pour les [__] au
coursneuve et on était assis à un table
et à un moment il y a un chanteur qui
vient vers nous qui salue tout le monde
tu étais avec un un jeune comédien assez
gros dont je me souviens plus du NOMON
ou qui é un pote à toi et les chanteurs
disparaî et ce chimoni dit mais c'était
qui et Florent qui conna bien tous les
chanteurs dit tu l' pas reconn card
mi
drôle fin finalement enlevé parce que je
trouva que ça fa la peine à
geor c'est des histoires
comme oui sauf que un jour c'est en
décembre en décembre 82 ah oui Dave est
à l'arbre de Noël de sa maison de 10à
l'époque c'est CBS et il y a une dame
qui vous dit quel plaisir de vous voir
on s'occupe tellement de vous Mons mon
et elle travaillit au service des
invendus c'est un peu le début de la
ch ENF pour conclure sur la promotion de
ce bouquin je DIRIS chers
téléspectateurs acheter le dernier livre
gétait bien ça très beau livream
[Applaudissements]
messieurs bien alors on passe au Blind
Test quel pays représenta cette chanson
à
l'Eurovision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je le dis pour qu'il y ait pas de
contestation à Street Veillon attendre
la fin de la réplique voilà vous
attendez la fin du Magnetto Magnetto je
suis une poupée de c une poupée de
son mon cœur est grave dans mes chansons
poupée de s poup de
sang suis-je meilleur suis-je pire une
poupée de
salon je vois la vie en rose de bonbon
poupée de s poupée de son voilà dans
quel
pays quel pays la Suisse la
Suisse bel non je pose la question à
Frédéric bedau c'est laurend quel pays
donc représenta cette chanson à
l'eurevision le Luxembourg bravo ouais
[Applaudissements]
la France moi je dis Suisse au début
point va qui alors Serge c'est le point
va à personne voilà
bravo celui qui a le droit de répondre
et celui qui a le buzer
àum regarder jeux à la télé ou quoi qui
qui commande tu poses une
question céit le Luxembourg en
attention
ser
viva la viv Viva
[Musique]
Victoria via Mar
vivaitt vousz
l'ITIE
le répond je suis
désoléé non tu as dit j'ai
entendu on
[Musique]
continueçise loin de ses jeux d'enfant
cétait
env
à raison de quitter sa maison pour se
trouver devant vous aujour
encore
vousz quel pays représenta cette chanson
l'urevision Marseille la France non non
qui c'est nous regarde on est allumé
c'est nous c'est nous on cal Monaco
ouais ouais
ou et ben voilà
bravo finalement la vie est pas si
injuste que ça c'est ça elle peut faire
le mieux elle peut faire bien la vie
merci la vie merci pour Julie mag
[Musique]
Serge couleur
de croire qu'on marchera
[Musique]
plus
quel pays représenta cette chanson le
Luxembourg non
nous lex comment vous saz çaon mon
producteur produit
laarf mais c'est bien bra bravo
flable
bien avoir plus de gros plans de Florent
Serge attention continue Magnetto
Serge le bleu de
l' la joie d'être
libre vous qui volez vers notre vie vous
qui volez vers l' demi ne
par
[Musique]
Ch
quel pays représentait cette chanson
l'urovision Laur
Dutch le point je le prends pas non il y
a eu
soufflage quand il y a soufflage il y a
perd d'age et on passe à celui qui
allumé ici c'est laiss donc
effectivement c'est la Suisse bravo
bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
ah oui oui oui oui Jul sont un peu
remontés ils sont à 6 Campan toujours à
3 avec c'est une
catastrofhe non pas du tout on a TR les
points on est à on é pour toi
la 7 9 pour vous 11 pour la voine et 6
pour
P
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien d'être le King oui c'est
génial vous partez en weekend vous êtes
parti pour partir alors on passe
maintenant au blind test numéro 9 un
blind test consacré à des chanteurs ou à
des acteurs qui chantent qui ont eu des
problème avec le
[Rires]
fisque c'est vrai c'est
drôle et là non pas du tout là je me
tourne vers vous flaurent pan parce que
parce que dans votre nouvel album qui
s'appelle Aland tiens Laurent si tu peux
montrer ça pendant que je parle voilà
non comme moi fais comme ça Laurent
voilà votre nouvel album s'appelle Aland
qui sort la semaine prochaine il y a un
single qui est déjà sorti qui s'appelle
ma liberté de penser qui est écrit par
Pascal Obispo et Lionel Florence et
alors vous dit en gros dans cette
chanson prenez-moi tout tout ce que vous
voulez mais vous n'aurez pas ma liberté
de penser voilà oui bah vous l'avez
résumé c'est exactement ça c'est ça
qu'est-ce que tu as voulu dire par là
merci merci de me poser la question B la
chanson c'estit ça
voilà
fait non je crois le mieux ça serait que
vous alliez la chanter finalement ah oui
c'est vrai que ça
enc FL
[Musique]
P quitte à tout prendre prenez mes
gosses et la
télé ma prossead mon revolver la voiture
ça c'est déjà fait avec les interdits
bancairs prenez ma femme le can
le micro-onde le frigidaire et même
jusqu'à ma vie privée de toute façon a
découvert je peux bien vendre mon âme au
diable avec lui on peut
[Musique]
s'arranger puisquici tout est négociable
mais vous n'aurez pas ma liberté de
penser
prenez mon lit les disques d'or ma bonne
humeur les petites cuillères tout ce
qu'à vos yeux a de la
valeur et donc je n'ai plus rien à faire
quit à tout prendre n'oubliez pas le
chit planqué sous l'étagère tout ce qui
est beau et compte pour moi je préfère
que ça parte à la bivière je peux donner
mon corps à la
science
s'il y a quelque chose à
[Musique]
prélever et que ça vous donne bonne
conscience mais vous n'aurez pas ma
liberté de
penser ma liberté de
[Musique]
pensée
je peux vider mes poches sur la
table ça fait longtemps qu'elles sont
[Musique]
trouées mais c'est mon froc j'en suis
capable mais vous n'aurez pas ma liberté
de penser
[Musique]
quitte à tout prendre et tout solder
pour que vos petites affaires s'arrang
je prends juste mon pyjama Ray je vous
fais cadeau des
oranges vous pouvez bien même tout
garder j'orterai rien en
enfer tout prendre je préfère y aller si
paradis vous est
off mon âme au
diable avec lui on peut
[Musique]
s'arranger puisquici tout est négociable
mais vous n'aurez pas non vous n'aurez
pas ma liberté de
penser ma liberté de
pens bravo
Florent flent messieurs ma liberté de
penser bravo bravo Florent merci beau ma
liberté de penser c'est extrait du
dernier CD de Florent panny qui
s'appelle
Aurland
[Applaudissements]
voilà je vous demande de vous
arrêter je vous demande de vous arrêter
quand c'est pas bal dur personne nécoute
bien alors P quand même c'est
extraordinaire parce que vous êtes passé
d'une certaine façon du belcau au
proteste song un petit peu non oui enfin
en même temps j'avais un peu déjà
démarré avec les protèes Song parce que
Mo j'ai démarré avec pres qui roule donc
flent vous êtes fait serrer par le
fisque ah bah moi j'ai toujours été ser
très près par le fisque finalement
c'estàd que le premier jour où j'ai
réalisé que j'allais gagner de l'argent
j'ai été les voir leur disant écoutez je
sais pas ce que c'est que déclarer ses
impôts ils ont dit on va vous expliquer
et comme vous l'aviez jamais fait ben on
va même vous en rajouter un peu donc mon
premier gros chèque il y avait la moitié
pour les impôts et l'autre moitié pour
les impôts donc et après ça ben j'ai
continué ils sont venus me voir en 91 et
jusqu'en 96 je les avais encore sur le
dos ils m'ont laissé tranquille en 97
ils sont revenus en 98 et nous sommes en
2003 et je les ai toujours mais on va
bientôt s'en sortir puisque je vais
habiter ailleurs est-ce que c'est pas un
peu poujadis de d'attaquer les impôts
les impôts ça sert à faire des crèches
des hôpitaux des routes oui oui bien sûr
ah non non on est bien d'accord que
l'impôt est nécessaire et moi je suis
ravi les r r ser à rien les RS ou et de
participer à à la société mais je crois
qu'il y a quand même un moment d'abord
on exagère beaucoup parce que ça coûte
quand même très très cher donc payer les
impôts d'accord mais peut-être on
pourrait payer moins et puis ensuite
dans des cas particuliers même si on est
en démocratie qu'on est tous égau dans
des cas particuliers on pourrait quand
même considérer qu'il y a de faire un
peu attention c'est-à-dire euh de mettre
dans le même panier les mecs qui sont en
train de tricher et de fruder et puis
ceux qui fin finalement savent pas
comment gérer leur pognon parce que du
jour au lendemain ça leur arriv il faut
peut-être pas faire l'amalgame quo
peut-être d'un seul cou se dire on peut
les protéger un peu quoi alors votre
nouvel album s'appelle Aland Aland c'est
la c'est la Patagonie oui ça peut oui
mais c'est ailleur quoi ouais c'est la
cour neuve c'est ce que tu veux th c'est
ton monde t aur tout dépend ce que tu as
fumé c'est ailleurs alors le 23 mai vous
êtes à l'Olympia aussi pour night of the
Proms pour night of the Proms qui est
devenu vraiment une institution musicale
c'est un mélange de de musique classique
et de pop musique oui enfin c'est en
fait c'est une c'est une compile concert
alors il y a voilà Julie Zenati qui sera
avec
nous et en fait c'est vrai que c'est
c'est une sorte de compile concert
compile où on a 80 musicien un
philharmonique complet qui qui s'amuse à
à enregistrer des titres pop et
accompagner des chanteurs pop avec des
arrangements philharmonique donc c'est
une tournée de de H dates au mois de mai
en effant on passe à l'olympi mais on se
promène un petit peu dans toute la
France et c'est plutôt rigolo de chanter
ses propres chansons avec 80 mecs
derrière qui jou et tous les instruments
et alors le 13 juillet vous êtes à
l'Olympia pour ce C concerts personnel
voilà et après vous avez un film qui
sort au mois de juillet qui s'appelle
quand je vois le soleil de Jac Cortal
voilà voilà
ou
t ça fait longtemps qu'ell
[Musique]
sontoué j'en suis capable mais vous
n'aurez pas
bien avec tout ça Florent P le fil aura
de quoi se servir PL c'est vrai que on
peut les remercier parce qu'ils ont
inspirer cette chanson et grâce à cette
chanson je vais certainement pouvoir
gagner beaucoup d'argent donc alors on
passe au
blind chanteurs beauoup ou les acteurs
qui chantent qui ont des problèmes avec
le
[Musique]
fis voilà donc on y va tout de suite
vous vous concentre
armand là il est pas du tout sur le coup
il est en train de
draguerindor mais pas du tout je mais
pas du tout je t'ai d ça fait mais
arrête mais me dis pas non à moi la
mauvaise for masculineou c'est çai je
comprends elle Bou allezy
allezy attention
[Musique]
Philippe c'esteux c'est simppreux
noneux jamais eu
problème cé ton prier jour
jrière bravo
ou bravo
révélation à ceux qui m'ont critiqué je
voudrais dire une chose moi dans ces
années considéré j'ai payé des impôts
très lourds peut-être pas aussi lourds
que voudrait la l'administration fiscale
mais j'ai payé des impôts très lourds je
voudrais leur dire à ces gens que moi
j'ai inv
j'ai investi 7 millions lourv dans la
construction Dutir je voudrais leur dire
enfin que lorsque l'on met des gens
comme moi au chômage c'est 10 100000
personnes selon les années que l'on met
au chômage voilà c'était
dans donc voilà vous nêtes pas tout seul
FL B la Barère vous inquiz pas marquez
un point bravo et JTI vous marquez un
point tous les deux c'est plutôt de qu'
trouvé là barrière c'est son époque M
attention
[Musique]
je
suisurard le point pour vous
ou je fais dans la fiscalité pourquoi
parce que je peux pas faire autrement ça
fait 30 ans que j'ai des relations avec
les impôts j'ai payé mes impôts j'étais
comme Monsieur j'ai du retard mais j'ai
jamais de problèm particulier il y a un
moment où on se trouve confronté à
quelque chose de colossal c'est pas un
être humain qui est en face de moi c'est
pas le percepteur elle n'est que
symbolique de quelque chose c'est par
rapport à une machine qui se réfugie
tout le temps derrière la frude derrière
la tricherie on n'est pas des tricheurs
on n pas des frudeurs voilà c'est je sa
Catherine c'est bravo ça fait un point
pour ok ok
[Musique]
Okan
bravo
[Applaudissements]
mes impôts parce que je peux
pas ça c'est réglé j'ai pas de quoi
c'est pas réglé c'est pas
réglé qu'est-ce que je peux faire c'est
pas parce que je suis pas un bon
français si j'avais de l'argent j'avais
les moyens de payer c'est pas une
question de bonne volonté c'est une
question d'argent ben voilà c'est tout
je l'ai pas en M dem trop je l'ai pas
bonû vous préféreriez les payer bon je
serais plus tranquille oui si je P mes
impôts je suis pas contre l'impôt mais
j'ai pas et voilà cétait j génial alors
points pour et julieti 3 points
bravo belle remontée belle remontée 3
points pour
Campan 7 points pour le r chez fréri
bed pas mal pas mal points
pour
et quand même 12 points pour Mar Lavoine
et
Maine et 6 points pour FL B elisa Tovati
voilà alors on passe au BL suivant mais
avant je vis m'adresser à vous Julie
Zenati vous aussi donc vous êtes dans la
night of the Proms avec Florent P
les 2 monoi
cou voilà et donc vous avez un deuxè
album qui sort qui s'appelle dans les
yeux d'un autre et le premier single
s'appelle la vie ce qu'elle veut
mesdames messieurs la vie fait tout ce
qu'elle
veut le pire le mux Orlando exige le
clip Magneto ser pour te donner ce que
j'ai de plus
grand j'ai mis du
temps j'ai mis du temps
et la vie fait tout ce qu'elle
veut le pire le
mieux le pire est le mieux
oui la vie fait tout ce qu'elle
veut le gris le
bleu le gris et le
bleu VO Jul
la vie fait ce qu'elle veut voilà alors
vous avez fait une édition pour devenir
fur de lu à l'époque vous aviez 15 ans
et demi plondon vous a vraiment épaulé
on peut dire vous le voyez toujours Luc
Plamondon je le croise de temps en temps
dans des spectacles non je le vois plus
beaucoup ouis il est pas trop déçu par
l'échec de Cindy je ne sais pas je pense
qu'il faudra lui poser la question ah ou
vous êtes prudent vous irez loin c'est
bien il faut jamais répondre à la télé
comme ça on fait carrière alors est-ce
que vous êtes réconcilié avec Hélène
seggara parce que vous avez eu un petit
des problèmes à l'époque c'est vous avez
piqué le rôle d'Esmeralda je CIS dire
non je pas non non je vais remettre les
trucs au clair je va jamais volé le rôle
d'Esmeralda ça s'est passé Hélène s'est
arrêté on m'a proposé de continuer et
puis elle m'a dit vas-y parce que tu vas
apprendre plein de trucs et voilà non
mais je dit sérieux vous en voulez pas
vous êtes vous en voulez c'est pas c'est
pas un reproche vous envoulez ah non
j'aime ce que je fais j'aime chanter ça
c'est sûr mais j'ai pas poussé hélè de
la scène pour prendre sa place pas
poussé dehors non non c'est pas ce que
dit Magneto
ça non mais c'est vrai qu' dans la cour
de l'école on vous appelait pas on vous
appelait pas Julie on vous appelait Jul
quoi parce que vous étiez quand même
assez ben oui qui a écrit les paroles de
titre convbi c'est JAC venerouso la
musique et quand il dit le gris le bleu
c'est quoi pour toi le gris le bleu le
gris le bleu ben c'est écoute le le gris
peut-être l'injustice que j'ai vécu ce
soir en tapant sur ce buzzer qui ne
s'allumait
pas on est pas là pour faire en
et le bleu le bleu c'est c'est de te
voir face à moi euh ah bonne réponse
bonne réponse bonne
réponse maindor don vous AZ hier soir
sur France 2 dans lacricrime ouais vous
avez été choisi parmi 65 comédiennes
ouais vous êtes fier de ça non pas la
clim la crime la c'est un peu la crime
juste pour ma promo tu as décidé de toi
la [__] les autres l'ont fait eux mê
non non moi aussi tu as vu la fait cour
c'est la soirée des
promoniqu ma copine je dis rien
moi oui sur France 2
voilàre jeune collègue patronnim
absolument imprononçable ben faites
comme nous le marchandez le Frédéric et
vous raccourciss en Fred pour un retour
en fanfare lacrime a recruté un nouveau
lieutenant charmant curieuse enquête je
vous l'accorde pour votre entrée
au voilàor dans la sur c'est le vendredi
mesdames messieurs voilà alors Maine oui
donc lacrime plus on a tout essayé avec
Laurent hier on a envie de vous dire
comment faites-vous non justement je
sais comment elle
fait ce que vous faites Maine c'est que
vous laissez Jérôme avec Gaspar à la
maison vous allez bosser et ce pauvre
Jérôme votre votre Jul on peut dire est
devenu une espèce de papa poule
complèement complètement complètement
castré quoi il paraît il paraît qu'il
met des langes à l'enfant oui mais donne
le biberon il se maquille tout seul en
tattendant il fait des barisilles vra
c'est ce mec est une épave rentre à la
maison vous l'avez castré ce pauvre
garçon pas du tout alors donc pour vous
un père qui s'occupe de son Maum c'est
un mec castré ben dit donc bah un mec
qui met des langes à un bébé qui lu
donne le bibon oui ENF c'est
dramatique tu l'as fait aussi mais non
il l'a pas fait il les a parqué en
Normandie lui c'est pas
vrai seul contre le reste du monde ch
c'est pire je suis avec toi ah voà voilà
quelqu'un qui ne lance que des enfants
de 32 ans et qui n donne le biberon qui
a des enfants de 32 ans les présentes
voilà c'est dev que j'aurais dû épouser
tu t'en vas toi pas du tout je
m'intéresse à cette émission qui me
passionne et je n'en perds pas une
miette et je suis toujours sur le cou
bien alors on va passer maintenant un
blind test un petit peu spécial hein les
garçons vous allez mettre vous allez
mettre masque vous ne saurez pas des
masques de qui et donc vous ne savez pas
qui vous allez représenter et vous avez
le droit de poser des questions euh et
les autres vont vont essayer de de vous
aider à trouver et ce pendant une minute
voilà c'est le blind test dis-moi qui je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suis voilà donc on va commencer avec
Lavoine vous mettez le premier masque à
laavine et il va tu ne dois pas voir qui
tu es voilà regarde personne voit tu ne
vois pas et les autres vont donc lui
expliquer répondre à ses questions pour
lui faire trouver attention ne lui dites
pas qui il est ne lui dites pas qui il
est attends il tu n'as pas le droit de
toucher maintenant tu ne dois pas
toucher pose des questions Marc suis-je
un homme oui est-ce tu es un homme plus
ou moins oui tu es un homme oui tu es un
homme oui homme un homme de couleur tu
es un homme de couleur aussi plus ou
moins vas-y vas-y donne la réponse
Michael Jackson Michael Jackson voilà
donc bravo bravo
bravo maintenant on va mettre le deè
masque attention ferme les yeux ferme
les yeux ferme
lesux voilà ne lui dites pas qui il est
il a pas le droit de
toucher Barbara mettezlui ce masque
comme il faut
PL bien Gérard alors pose des questions
maintenant
je suis un homme
ou est cheveux excuse-moi
compliqu chanteur acteur h politique un
homme politique qui a été Président de
la
République est
toujours il a été
avant est-ce qu'il a été président la
République française merci beaucoup pas
de problème président des
États-Unis récent ou c'est pas
Clinton bravo bravo un point pour Mar
la très très bien joué très très bien
joué maintenant c'est Laur dudge qui va
avoir masque
suiv extraordinaire comment tu as fait
j'ai joué
intelligemment très bien jou Barbara
c'est c'est nan nan vous mettez son
masque à la fermez les yeux s'il vous
plaît ferme les yeux Laurent Laur ferme
les yeux voilà
attention poignons bon c'est un bonhomme
oui c'est un chanteur non c'est un
musicien un
comédien français américain il est mort
il est vivant mais il en a ch
il je peux dire qu'il en a ch récemment
est sorti en France qui a cartonné pas
trop récemment il cartonne pas trop il
est il a les cheve
il a les cheveux longs oui euh il aime
bien ses cheveux il trouve qu'ils sont
assez beau ileve d'accord c'est
important mais il s'aime bien il s'aime
bien euh il est américain ouais oui
euh de naissance non il a eu un Oscar
oui oui il a eu un Oscar il a un nom
composé non maise ton masque c'est
chiant mais j'arrive pas ça puis le
masque je m'approche trop il pue un peu
quand même je sens du masque moi c'est
impressionnant perdu et voilà
vous étiez syvester st
ouioup flent un
point alors on passe maintenant à
Florent
effectivement vous
allez je l' mon masque vous
écoute alors je suis un
homme donc je fais la même chose que
tout le monde un chanteur actur
politique c'est ouioui
Chirac de toute façon il y en a plus
qu'un d'OM politique français c'est
Chirac donc c'est le seul il a raison
c'est le seul qui reste donc voilà donc
ça fait un point pour vous un point pour
la voine un point pour juste pour me
dire qu'on vient de passer au
zapping ça tombe bien qu'on voit Chirac
j'ai de mots à lui dire vas-y non je
plaante sur les impôts bien on continue
avec Campan
maintenantzz ferme les yeux ferme les
yeux Bernard trou ferme les yeux Bor non
c'est
dégueulasse attention oh tu es beau ah
que tu es
beau attention
Bernard tou le droit tuas le droit de
toucher non tu touches pas alors j'ai
trouvé c'est qui j'ai trouvé con con
prière
question je sais pas un homme oui pas
toucher ouais réfléchis bien tu as le
droit de toucher tu tu parles presque
comme lui un politique non chanteur
oui regard euh ça dépend pour qui non tu
dois TR ringar
non pas du tout ringar il a la classe ça
dépend
pour je sais pas tu raconte il est
Pasard je peux pas tou pas très connu
c'est pas facile hein non non non on a
pas le droit de toucher continue Bernard
allez je sais pas B il est mort il est
vivant il est est vivant Viant il est
vivant c'estent c'est c'est
trop oui trouvéou bravo
voilà donc voilà donc les points sont
attribués à Marc Lavoine Gérard Armond
ah il reste
[Musique]
un email ti un email pour me dire qu'il
reste
dev c'est incroyable chanteur ou non
c'est c'est qui c mais on voit pas j'end
pas question femme ou homme h ça a l'air
d'être un homme politique oui oui
français non américain
ouentou non oui vivant oui qui a dit oui
président non président
ouiésidentésident alors
Bou
[Applaudissements]
bravo je cro que c'était Nixon c'est
bouant pour dire que ce jeu n'était pas
facile bravo à
tous
alors un point pour la voine un point
pour un point pour pas de point pour
Dutch un point pour P un point pour
Campan voilà le rappel des scores ah ben
là c'est énorme là c'est énorme c'est
Marc Lavoine qui est sûr d'emballer la
petite morindor à Jérôme il va pouvoir
s'occuper du bébé il va pouvoir langer
il va pouvoir donner le biberon le
Jérôme vous vous serez à Bagdad à
l'hôtel Palestine avec Marc Lavoine en
vacances parfait bravo alors la finale
des batttu sera
la finale des
battu sera entre Campan NES
et ah oui après il y a deux execos Dutch
al il y a Dutch et P on va vous
départager avec un blind test de secours
qui s'appelle le blind test du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
téléphone alors Florent P vous écoutez
avecti la chanson interprétée par par
mon portable et vous me dites donc qui
chantait l'original attention
[Musique]
Philippe on ne souffle pas au soleil
c'est jifer qui a dit au soleil c'est
elle mais elle a pas dit qui elle a pas
dit qui Jennifer au soleil bra par
Jennifer on l'a tous dit à
mon de répondre soyez pas mauvaise
joueuse
vous êtes qualifié d'office pour la
finale des battu donc n'essayez pas de
fout la merde dans cette émission est en
train de savoir qui va êtreosé à vous
fin c'est un
honneurer attention phipe il un email
pour me dire c'est quand même pas mal
foutu ce système de Blind Test de
secours parce que finalement tu t'en es
servi et les gens l'ont remarqué donc
bravo chapeau
bas attention attention PhIP
[Musique]
email pour me dire qu' sont Gour en
ré l'interprète je veux
[Musique]
l'interprète alors maintenantourne
vous
tion je voulais
appelle c'est
[Musique]
johnyors je me retourne vers vous
maintenant attention attention Frédéric
et Laurent écoutez
bien
l'interprte
c'est bon on a
[Musique]
gagné personne souffle c'est trop grave
c'est trop grave c'est prenant c'est
trop grave c'est
prant pas beaucoup de mais c'est bien
[Musique]
FD voilà et ben donc voilà c'est comme
ça maintenant encore une pour vous je pe
je peux donner la
répéit c'était l bravo voil
donc
c'est bien c'est bien Laurent Dutch et
Frédéric Bos qui pour la finale débatue
seront opposés donc à Bernard Campan etz
donc on passe à la finale
débattue voilà et donc le thème de la
finale des batttu c'est les chansons que
si tu sais qui chante c'est la
[Musique]
honte
attention vous êtes prêts donc ça se
joue entre vous attention
[Musique]
PHPP
voilà attention
[Musique]
PHPP
pas
regretter e vous dans les chansons que
si tu sais qui c'est c'est la honte vous
êtes très
fort ça c'est les fait Top 50 faites
gaffe vous y êtes donc attention
attention la dernière chanson vous êtes
même même quand c'est les
chansonsar moi c'est le coup de la
mélodie tout à l'heure c'est ton
portable tu aurais pris un numérique
comme moi tu aurais bien capté
ch
attention c'est la danse des canards
[Musique]
bravo crois donc
que le gage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
infme
vous refaites l'émission mieur voilà
vous allez chanter levez-vous vous allez
chanter mais pourquoi c'est pour
nous non si vous avez reconnu vous êtes
les meilleurs des des ringars donc c'est
à vous
[Musique]
n c'est comme ça la vie est injuste vous
mtez sur scène chantez quand vous allez
voir ce que vous devez chanter prenez
vos micros je
rien bien donc vous allez nous
interpréter je peuxavoir là la chanson
qui apparaît sur le grand écran derrière
moi attention Bernard Campan ns c'est à
[Musique]
vous chaque jour le sable les jeux dans
l'eau mon rêve était trop beau les qui
s'achè pas vous trper les amis
maintenant
chanter franchement vous êtes
comment t
sour tellement de
souvenir bravo BJ on arrête là non je
crois que je crois que le gage a été
suffisant ah ouais je reconnais Bernard
Bernard sale soirée sale soirée pour
Bernard Campan qui se retrouve en train
de chanter du RO vois on reconnait quand
même que c'est encore une femme qui SAU
la ouais ouais ouais ouais moi j'ai
remarqué ça
aussime on est d' heureusement que n
était là heureusement que NES était
là et donc maintenant on va passer à la
finale qui va se dérouler entre vous
quatre la finale c'est quels sont ces
belles chansons françaises totalement
détru attends juste un email pour me
dire mais bordel quelle belle
finale les
gens ba les gens les gens sont sous le
charme quoi ça marche bien la mayonnaise
fr on passe à la
[Musique]
finale donc maintenant Marc Lavoine
maindor Gerard Armand Veillon vous allez
devoir reconnaître ces belles chansons
françaises totalement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
détrues
prière chanson écoutez
[Musique]
bien que la montagne
belle très bien on continue donc attends
c'est Dar la S me demande c'est d'And
qui a marqué le
point la S joue aussi c'est des gens il
jouent on voit
danserour heureuse re sois
BR oui bravo ça fait un point
partout un point partout et voici
maintenant le point décisif la balle de
match qui va trouver la chanson
totalement détruite aura gagné la finale
un email la allez
GG je ne sais pas à qui ça s'adresse
psgg ça tombe comme çapt GG c'est psgg
attention
[Musique]
Philipp que c'est trist benise navour
bravo
et voilà c'est donc
maineor et Mar Labine c'est le récite
quand vous partez en weekend ensble pour
de vrai vous allez où à Vénise il y a
pas de problème donc maintenant pour
savoir qui est le meilleur ou la
meilleure entre vous deux maindor et Mar
Lavoine on va passer à la super
[Musique]
finale
[Rires]
Maine tu commences cette super finale et
cette super finale c'est le contre
la
attention attention
attentionindor non non c'est vous qui
commencez je suis un homme galant
attention attention je vais vous donner
des titres de
chansons pour dire que tu as dit tro
fois attention les gens suivent
attention ti regarde ça VI de
tomber donc tu donnes un titre de
chanson et je te donne le nom de
l'interprète en une minute tu dois en
dire le plus possible ma attention
top
paradis on pas là pour
fa attention critique est aisé mais le
direct est
[Applaudissements]
difficiletiontion
paste Lili voulaz aller danser euh
Julien claire Couleur Café euh gazbourg
non ah
oui Dancing Queen quoi Dancing Queen
Dancing Queen ah bah oui les yeux revolv
Marc
lavoan W les les YMC les Village People
cargo Arel BO
superstition C Wonder cette annéelà
cette
annéel TR Enis j'ai 10 ans j'ai 10 ansin
Souchon tout le monde le sa Staying
Alive les
B vous pouvez passer pouvez passer je
passe Love To Love You Baby Love arrête
non Love To Love baby je sais pas je
passe elle passe Boog Wonder et
voilà vous en avez trouvé 13 en une
minute bravo on va voir si Maran fait
mieux que vous attention Mar Laan vous
êtes prêt vous avez une minute la mère
ça va pas attention top chrono Pen It
Black passe laissez-moi danser je passe
asser uner ketchup let's all chant je je
passe comment te dire
adieu François hardardi Le poonneur des
Lilas ginbourg Only You les plateurs l'
Tesse de l'air du Tron changer tout
Jonas jardin d'hiver jardin d'hiver
c'est
non Salvador je cours tout seul ch le
petit pain au chocolatin Indy village
popo au mon bateau éc Morena besoin de
personne Sanson Véronique Sanson
toulousearo la route de Memphis
Mitel lettre à France Paul narf les
petites femmes de Pigal Lama l'au vive
Bard chasseur d'Ivoire chanfor babouka
babouka
c'est
alors qui a
gagné 17 c'est Marou un email pour me
dire que jamais Labine n'a aussi bien
porté son
nom bravo Marc Labine vous êtes donc le
grand gagnant de ce premier grand BL et
vous partez en
weekend rassure-nous premier mais pas
dernier donc c'était le grand blind test
avec Elisa tovti son album s'appelle ang
[Musique]
ur Olymp 2003 le 10
Ju Lund à
M
1 é à 18h le samedi Laurent Dutch
bienvenue chez les roses de Francis
paluo avec Laurent Dutch Caro Bouet Jean
du jardin André V et Michel du chaois
plus la bande originale du film
Bienvenue chez les roses et puis la
reine de beauté de linan du 22 avril au
28 mai au Théâtre de l'Ouest parisien
Frédéric Bos One to One sur MCM CAD
Olivier mais qui a tué pamé la rose de
avec Olivier Gérard et jean-pa rou çaort
le 4 juin à veillons la salle de bain
d'astri Veillon avec Astrid Veillon FL
gentil Mathilde péninena sou et Pascal
Robert c'est tous les soirs à la Comédie
de
Paris en passant au Pr au clair mesdames
messieursindor on a tout essayé la crime
le vendredi sur France 2 FL l'album
s'appelle
il sort le 8 avril et le single
s'appelle ma liberté de
penser en tournée avec night of theom le
23 mai à l'Olympia de Paris et en
concert à l'Olympia à partir du 13
juillet voilà et puis un film qui
s'appelle quand je vois le soleil de
Jacques Cortal voilà Julie Zenati
l'album s'appelle dans les yeux d'un
autre et le single s'appelle la vie fait
ce qu'elle veut en tournée avec la night
of the prom le 23 mai à l'olymp de Paris
voilà merci à
tous franchement quel [__] de bonne
idée quoi bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à ş
ş